we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P I love it
when I get voicemails like this many of
you know English is my second language
now I initially spoke Spanish for the
first roughly six years of my life I
came to the US knowing two words stop
and blew and I remember seeing a stop
sign when we arrived and left the
airport in 1989 and because I
immediately recognized a word I thought
this is gonna be great I'm gonna do
great at this so anyway I got a
voicemail from someone who considers
themselves sort of a linguist and who is
saying David I know English is your
second language you used a word that
doesn't exist yesterday except the word
does exist take a listen to this
voicemail hey Dave this is doc Smith
calling look it's a little bit of a
language I just wanted to tip you off
you kind of use the word that didn't
exist about nine minutes nine minutes or
so in your show on the seventh you
talked about the framers you were
talking about checks and balances and
how the framers never anticipated having
somebody like President Trump who would
slouch wrong word the word is want FL 8
u n either is men in that flaunt the
norms now to your credit English is your
second language I understand that and I
can also take I've heard several other
media folks also use that listen if you
are a linguist I would imagine you would
google the word the word is flout FL o
UT and it sounds like you are a native
English speaker but I understand that we
do have problems in the United States
with with education
the word is flout the definition is to
openly disregard to disregard a rule or
a law a convention or a norm I spoke
correctly Donald Trump is flouting the
checks and balances and norms and laws
that were put in place by the framers of
the United States in that he is
disregarding them it's not flaunting
flaunting would actually be the wrong
word here flout is the correct word the
more you know
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about that Covington High
School lawsuit we will talk about
alcohol-related deaths up drastically in
the United States and a very interesting
universal basic income trial being
funded by a Japanese billionaire all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
get access instantly at join pakman.com